what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we actually have
quite a bit of information about
spider-man no way home specifically
involving andrew garfield and toby
mcguire when they are going to be
appearing in the film and what type of
role they are going to have in the film
also a bit of information about what the
villains are going to look like
and a little bit more information about
that trailer and the great thing is
is that all of these reports today are
coming from very legitimate sources
so today we're not talking about wild
and crazy rumors we're talking about
stuff that is actually going to happen
in the movie
and i think some fans might not
particularly enjoy this report
especially if you are a tom holland
spider-man fan if he is your favorite
you may not like this report however if
you are
a andrew garfield or toby maguire
spider-man fan then you probably will
like this report
and of course if you want to stay up to
date with spider-man no way home be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
i have clearly been doing a lot of
spider-man videos lately
but with all the leaks coming out it's a
ton of fun so let's go on
with this first report and this first
report is coming from daniel
richmond or daniel rbk depending how you
know him for those of you who may not
know daniel he's an insider his reports
on when to expect
trailers are insanely accurate and he's
had a lot of inside scoops confirmed
over time and today he has a report for
us
or at least we're getting one from
something that he said so originally
there were reports going around and i
don't remember from whom because they
weren't confirmed but there were reports
going around
that stated that toby maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man were
going to be appearing
in spider-man no way home towards the
end in the third act
this is something that seemed pretty
believable at the time after all it's
really tom holland's spider-man movie or
at least it was
so it would make sense that he would get
most of the spotlight for most of the
film
so nobody really questioned this however
there are conflicting reports today
and these are more likely going to
happen and this is kind of a two-part
report the first part is when daniel
replied to a tweet on twitter
somebody asked him if toby is a
supporting role or a
action cameo and his reply was i heard
that from the moment they appear in the
movie toby and andrew become
co-leads to holland now this is the
report that i was talking about in the
beginning where i stated some people may
not like this
especially if you are a tom holland fan
a lot of people were kind of upset with
the doctor strange announcement when
they stated that doctor strange was
going to be appearing in spiderman no
way home as sort of a mentor for peter
parker
a lot of people were pretty upset about
this because they want tom holland
spider-man to be on his own in
spider-man homecoming he had tony stark
in civil war avengers end game and
avengers infinity war again he had tony
stark
even though he saved tony's life at one
point and in game and then in spider-man
far from home he had another mentor and
that mentor was really happy
mysterio faked it for a while and peter
was pretty happy to have him as a mentor
but of course we know how that played
out but happy brought the plane brought
the new suits gave him the pep talk
and that was fine because that was a
little bit less mentorship than he had
in the previous film and fans really
wanted to see spider-man go out on his
own in spider-man no way home but it
doesn't appear that's going to be the
case
now it looks like he's not only going to
have doctor strange but also toby
maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man as well
fighting right beside him however don't
get too upset about this yet because if
we think about this it kind of makes
sense if we consider what the movie is
really going to be about and where
the villains are coming from the movie
is really about the multiverse there's
going to be a multiversal problem
right there will be villains coming into
the main universe from other different
universes
and some of these villains are going to
be a little bit more beyond
our peter parker a little bit more for
him to handle and if you consider the
fact that there are going to be
like six seven villains in this film
essentially the sinister six
he's going to need some help our peter
has come a long way but he is definitely
going to need some help to take on
six or seven villains alone and it
sounds like that could happen pretty
soon because the second half of this
report is
replying to daniel stating that andrew
and toby are going to be co-leads
a person then said awesome i hope they
come halfway through
instead of the end in which daniel
replied they
are so toby and andrew are seemingly
going to appear halfway through the film
which would make sense as far as the
movie is concerned if you're going to
have a bunch of villains breaking out
from the multiverse it would make sense
that the other heroes come at the same
time
and from this moment where all of the
villains come from different universes
and we get toby and andrew this is
really where dr
strange's role comes in obviously doctor
strange too the multiverse of madness is
going to be dealing with the multiverse
in
madness which is seemingly going to
start in loki and keep in mind
michael waldron who wrote loki and
doctor strange 2
told me personally when i interviewed
him that there are some things
in loki that will affect doctor strange
2 which of course will in turn affect
spider-man no way home so at the center
of it all at the center of the
multiverse exploding doctor strange is
there and his focus in spider-man
knowing home is probably going to be
figuring out how to get these villains
back so i wouldn't expect to
see a ton of him most of the focus
should be on tom holland at first a
little bit of doctor strange and then on
the three spider-man
while cutting back to doctor strange
every now and then seeing how closing
that multiversal portal is going
and who knows doctor strange may even
bring in the other spider-man himself to
help our peter parker that may be
something we never figure out until the
movie comes out but of course if i hear
anything i'll update you and as far as
the villains are concerned
daniel did put out another reminder in a
tweet that the green goblin is going to
be the main villain of the film
and speaking of villains it looks like
we got a little bit more info today on
what they're going to look like
and this report is coming from superhero
theorists at murphy's multiverse.com
and the people over there have come in
with some pretty clutch leaks lately
specifically superhero theorist and we
got some information from them
replying to a tweet that said all i want
is a more accurate looking goblin not
that power ranger bs we got from the
first film
in which superhero theorists replied
expect the old but prepare for the new
the fashion for the winter collection is
going to be lovely this year
purple hoods and green outfits yellow
shirts and green jackets
purple pants and lab coats green shirts
and khakis and trench coats with
tentacles will all be in season now
obviously this
is a description of what some of the
villains are going to look like but i
want to specifically focus on the green
goblin because it looks like there's
going to be a key difference between the
green goblin we see
in this film and what we saw before in
the past the description for the green
goblin is purple hoods and green outfits
now the purple hood implies that the
green goblin is not going to have a
helmet or a mask
in fact in another tweet superhero
theorist said one of the things that
scared me as a kid
with defoe's green goblin was that we
never actually saw his face when he was
green goblin except for a few times and
he was able to strike fear with just his
voice alone
imagine what he'll look like now when he
doesn't have the mask
now at one point in time there were
reports stating that the villains were
going to be taking from their respective
universes right before they die
and if this is true that means the green
goblin did not have a mask on right
before he died
in the very first spider-man film now
it's not confirmed if that is indeed
when the villains are going to be taken
from their universes but if it is true
that would explain why the green goblin
has no mask
and he apparently is going to be wearing
a purple hood and i personally
am really looking forward to seeing this
and the other villains and what little
twists they give them
now of course as i said there has been a
little bit of a trailer update and i
wouldn't leave you without talking about
that now this report comes from again
daniel richman and he is
extremely accurate when it comes to
trailers and yesterday on twitter he
said to be clear i usually hear a few
days before
nothing yet so likely not dropping this
week and was told not to expect it
anytime soon now immediately when i read
this tweet i checked with my trailer guy
who was usually very accurate about when
trailers are dropping as well he was
accurate about shanghi
the eternals etc and this person
basically stated the same thing
haven't heard anything yet and if it was
coming out soon i would have
so sadly i wouldn't expect it soon now i
have heard reports stating that it could
be coming with black widow
but i personally actually think that
they would wait until loki
is over with before releasing the
trailer because i think the ending is
really going to set up the multiverse of
madness and spider-verse
and again daniel's very accurate with
trailer releases and my guy said the
same thing so at this point in time i'm
not expecting it with black widow but
we'll have to wait and see but let me
know your thoughts on these reports in
the comments down below are you happy or
mad about this report that states toby
mcguire and andrew garfield are going to
be co-leads and coming in about halfway
through the film
let me know in the comments down below
and don't forget to like this video and
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest spider-man or
mcu videos for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
me